things can be red hot they can be white
hot they can even be blue hot but what
comes after that well as it turns out
nothing as the temperature of an
idealized black body grows the intensity
of the visible radiation it emits falls
into an Ever more slowly changing tail
given the biology of the human eye past
a certain temperature a final color will
be reached this is what it looks like
it's been called the color of infinite
temperature but it's also the color of
our new Beanie you'll get this in your
next curious osity box if you're a
member or if you join soon this is the
color of the hottest anything can be you
could make something this hot hotter but
it's color wouldn't change of course at
a certain point the concentration of
heat would be so intense an a vent
Horizon would form trapping all of the
energy in a black hole known as a cou
blitz but you already knew that because
you're not just hot oh no you are a coug
[Music]
blitz